[Music]
hello I'm Rosemary Knight a professor in
the geophysics department at Stanford
letting you know about a new online
course now available harnessing the
power of GIF is glimaging to recharge
California's groundwater
this course accompanies the web-based
app we have created fastpath that allows
you to work with geophysical data your
data or publicly available data to
evaluate potential sites for recharge
specifically looking for fast paths from
the ground surface to the water table
thus the name of our app
so join us and harness the power of
geophysical Imaging to support the
planning and implementation of managed
Aquifer recharge throughout California
it's the way forward for sustainable
groundwater management
[Music]
foreign